[Musique]
le financement est un élément important
dans l'activité de ski cube nous avons
un outil spécifique qui est initiative
50 en Yvelines et qui permet d'amorcer
la pompe en termes de financement
[Musique]
c'est une structure qui était mise en
place par l'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin il y a quelques années
sous une formation susceptive et qui
mobilise des fonds publics et privés
donc on a beaucoup d'entreprises du
territoire qui abondent à ce fond que
nous mettons à disposition au travers de
près d'honneur un disposition des
entreprises des porteurs de projets
initiative Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
c'est aujourd'hui environ une
cinquantaine de près donc ils vont voilà
globalement de 5000 à 100.000 euros avec
une moyenne d'environ 30 000 euros on
est environ 120 près en traitement
chaque année puisque les durées de
remboursement varient entre 3 et 5 ans
on a plus de 97% de des prêts que nous
proposons aux entreprises qui sont
remboursées auprès de 3,5 ans donc très
peu d'échecs finalement
[Musique]
nous avons
la société l'accord qui au travers de la
participation capitale d'une entreprise
d'une belle PME du territoire intermé sa
réussit à lever plus d'un million de
d'euros donc ce qui est déjà
particulièrement important et puis
récemment corporating qui elle aussi
d'ailleurs avait bénéficié en amont
d'initiative saint-anton Yvelines au
travers et qui vient de lever plus de 2
millions de d'euros de fond on a
d'autres start-up qui est actuellement
le sont en cours de levée de fonds et on
espère que ça devrait bien fonctionner
avec la près de 10 millions d'euros pour
l'une d'entre elles et on attend
confirmation l'Espagne dans les tous
prochains mois